[Music]
hello again ladies and gentlemen
everybody's here eating biscuits with
hot sauce and grape jelly he said he had
to try it because it was free i told him
it was free
but he said it wasn't great but it
wasn't it wasn't terrible either i mean
that's kind of how i feel about it it's
an acquired taste that's an acquired
taste
i'm not a big hot sauce fan you know
what i'm saying yeah no it's got to be
like tabasco or that
crystals louisiana hot sauce one or two
yeah
yeah put it on there you spread it on
the meat get it kind of soak in a little
bit
then you take some grape jelly you put
it on top of there and then just eat the
biscuit like that and it's gotta
gotta have sausage probably yeah
probably wouldn't be as good with with
ham
yeah probably wouldn't be as good with
ham yeah hot sauce and ham don't really
go together yeah
and we were eating them on on um
sausage biscuits that didn't have any
cheese either it was just a biscuit
with sausage in the middle of it yeah
like from waffle house
yeah yeah it was like that like just the
no frills
i think we were getting them from um
wards
oh man remember wars montgomery wars no
wars or just ward's wars
it's a mississippi chain rewards yeah
it's kind of like
i don't know if we had any of those it
was a hamburger it's a hamburger chain
oh okay yeah real crappy looking but
it's good on the inside
fried chicken sandwich fried chicken um
i like a good fried chicken salad yeah
i think black people own it yeah i think
so yeah so they make the good [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] right [ __ ] right it's
like a black owned chain
i think i'm pretty sure what if it's
still there
oh yeah it's it's still around because i
went to go see my dad
for his surgery wards was still there i
was eating it well [ __ ] that was only a
couple years ago yeah a couple years ago
yeah interesting and like we said on the
show yesterday that we were making some
pumpkin bread and it was in the oven and
it came out of the oven and it was
delicious yeah even though you forgot to
cream the butter and sugar together
first it didn't matter
but it didn't end up mattering at the
end it turned out
it turned out okay for breakfast this
morning
bring me back to awards that's funny
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure that's a black
family that owns that it's a small
chain i think it's only mississippi
maybe alabama maybe a little bit of it
no
in louisiana um
i think i think it's black owned just
only black people work there
i've never seen a white person working
there you gotta be a cute black chick to
work there
so it's like yeah or or old black lady
there's only one of the two there's
nothing
no one else is representing well in the
back there he's got black guys cooking
yeah yeah but what you see up front is
just the old ladies are like
16 17 year old black girls oh yeah it is
a veteran's day today isn't it
yeah yeah i just found out a couple a
couple hours ago i don't really care
about it well i only know because it
comes up on my little mac and it goes
burnt and it makes like a little fart
noise like
i don't know why the mac makes that
noise when it tells you it's a holiday
but whatever
all right so the movie we were talking
about today is another one that i had
heard about previously
and then i saw that it was streaming on
hulu this is from 2017 and it's a
canadian movie and it's called
pie whack it now this movie
it's pretty much i mean there's other
characters in it but it's mostly like
uh the main two actors which is like a
mother and daughter now the mother
is played by uh lori holden who famously
played andrea on the walking dead
and uh was all she was in the midst too
right i want to say yeah i think she was
she's good at playing like [ __ ]
characters and she is also indeed a
[ __ ] character in this
um and it's also directed by adam
mcdonald who i found out
was the same guy that directed
backcountry which i'm pretty sure
is that killer bear movie that was like
based on a true story which was actually
quite good if you haven't seen that one
i think that one's on tv
it's really good like really gory [ __ ]
like when the guy gets attacked by the
bear or whatever like i said it's based
on our true story
this movie's pretty interesting this one
this one was pretty good
it's now i'm gonna say um it's much more
in the creepy slow burn
type of vibe not super action-packed um
it's kind of like
it's basically what happens is there's
this teenage girl named
leah and um her dad has died
just in some undetermined way and she
has turned to
the evil goth occult subculture yeah and
has started hanging out with a bunch of
gothy teens well it's kind of like goth
and
black metal put together yeah which you
know there is some christmas they were
listening to metal they had good music
again they were listening to the metal
they were also listening to the lord's
lord's church was in there that was nice
they were listening was it um
was it um what was the other one that i
recognized wasn't it like brian eno
it might well there was some music this
some of the score sounded very bright
brian you know yeah that's right that's
an obvious that's what i was talking
about
i don't know if it actually was but it
did some of the score sounded like
something off of david bowie's low album
yeah sort of like some decent music in
it like i said like some black metal as
well so i was like even though it's set
in the present day it's not set in the
80s no but the kids were into the retro
[ __ ]
yeah which you know fair enough that's
when all the good [ __ ] was happening
when all the good [ __ ] came out yeah
but uh yeah so she uh so she gets into
the occult her mom doesn't like it her
mom
they don't really say i don't know if
her mom's just like kind of a raging
[ __ ] wad or if she has
like or if she's like bipolar or
something i think it was kind of like
the way she was acting was almost like
she was bipolar because she would like
go all [ __ ] ragey and then the next
day she'd be like
hey what's up and then act like nothing
happened
so uh so basically she's like well
i can't you know the mom is like i can't
stay in this house anymore it's like we
have to move
so uh teen has a teen tantrum because
she does not want to move away from her
friends uh they're moving out in the
middle of nowhere like you do in a
horror movie
and um even though her mom is like a
kind of an [ __ ] like a friend she
says like some pretty unforgivable like
shitty
stuff to her daughter like admittedly
but she does kind of cave in and be like
okay well i'll drive you
back to your old school like at least
until the end of the year so you can
still hang out with your friends and
[ __ ] like that
so she's driving her like an hour you
know each way so she can go to the same
school and she can like stop bitching
but after this one huge argument that
they have and the mom
says something like i said admittedly
very shitty that you should never say to
your
kid um leah the daughter
decides i'm gonna use this occult [ __ ]
that i have
going on and i'm going to summon a demon
to kill
my mom so she does the ritual and then
the bulk of the movie is kind of like
her waiting to see if the demon's gonna
come and like what's gonna happen
and like kind of vague creepy things
like happen in the house like she keeps
hearing
something that sounds like it maybe has
hooves
like walking around up in the attic um
she has a friend stay over
and the friend like wigs the [ __ ] out
and won't tell them what
she saw um so all and there's like dirt
on the floor and the door is always
always open like somebody came in from
outside
so it's always that kind of thing and um
it's
it's interesting because it kind of
keeps it
i want to say it almost kind of keeps it
ambiguous because for a while i was
sitting there going
now i wonder if they're going to go the
direction of
you know it wasn't really like the demon
never showed up it was just like her
guilty conscience or whatever
i don't know if they left it that
ambiguous though you know what i'm
saying
yeah because the friend did see
something in the house even though they
never show what the friend saw and they
never
she never says what she saw she was just
like so freaked out she's like take me
home i'm never coming back here i think
it's like demon
yeah well and they do show it like at
the end but like i said it's very very
subtle but like this had like some
really creepy i really really liked i
think you were out in the other room or
in the bathroom or something
this one scene where leah wakes up in
the middle of the night and like she
heard something kind of creaking around
and then up in the corner of room
there's just like a shadow and you can't
quite tell what it is like it kind of
looks like a person it's very hereditary
you know what i mean where it's like
a suggestion of something like up in the
corner and then all of a sudden like a
leg
comes down like like it's up there like
in the corner like that and like it
starts to come down like that and it's
just the shadow
but i think they did i think it was cool
the way they kind of
kept it out like they kind of kept it in
the shadows she couldn't see entirely
what
pie wack it looked like well it's hard
to scare somebody but it's hard to scare
somebody with the way [ __ ] looks
nowadays everybody's seen everything
and that's and yeah and so i think that
it was good that they showed some
restraint because
like you said you know it's very easy to
be like
and have like something pop up in your
face it's got big black eyes and a big
stretchy mouth
you know it's like everybody's seen that
now that was like when remember when we
went to the theater and saw a lot of the
la yourona yeah i thought that was
[ __ ]
that was freaking me out that was
freaking out the kids in the audience
too
until it got to a point where they
showed it too much yeah you can't show
your mind you can't
show it for too much it was freaking me
out for
about the first one third of that movie
seeing that thing i was like that that's
pretty [ __ ] bad that thing
that scary ass woman yeah but then they
show
in one scene they showed it to me for
too long they showed its face
yeah for too long which totally
demystified it
dumb well and like i said too i think
that i mean just like
every era of horror movies you're gonna
have like your kind of go-to
scary monster looking thing so i feel
like since the james wan conjuring
movies came out and um you know those
kind of movies of that ilk
i feel like pretty much every sort of
indie movie not every indie movie but a
lot of indie movies that are just like
want a
quick scare they'll have like a woman
that looks like
it's like they always have black eyes or
their face stretches out
like their mouth goes you know what i
mean they
so there's a lot of that going on like i
feel like it started in that might
i don't know if the stretchy face thing
started in the exorcism of emily rose
that might have been the first one that
i saw it in but now it's like in every
[ __ ] movie
um so i liked that in this one you never
really got a good sense of what pie wack
it looked like
it was just like a suggestion you know
what i mean so i think it was kind of
like
in like sometimes you'd see her from
like far away or it's like sometimes
she'd just be in the shadow
and it was like i think it was much
creepier like that now that said this is
a movie that you really have to
like sit down and kind of immerse
yourself in because a lot of it
because you said when we first started
watching it yeah that you were getting
impatient with it because you thought it
was kind of boring
well it was a weird mixture of stuff
where it was good
it was a good idea it had a good cast it
was looking good it was sounding good
it was giving me too much information
though it was it was taking too long
yeah you know what i mean that first
half hour
you could have cut about 10 minutes of
that out and here and there just of the
and for me i started to get a little
bored with it
my mind started to wander started
thinking about other things yeah
but then like it kind of picked up and
then yeah it started to pick up later
but that first half hour needs to be
trimmed up i would trim it i trimmed 10
minutes off of that
but other than that like i said so this
is a very atmospheric
yeah a lot of [ __ ] is suggestion a lot
of [ __ ] is like just creaky noises
like a shadow in the corner like dirt on
the floor like stuff like that so it's
very very low-key
yeah i think what they were trying to do
is they were trying to build up tension
by making it start a little slowly but
it
but it didn't do that not for me it just
yeah i just started my mind started
to wander started thinking about other
things i think it started to do that a
little bit more like toward not like
toward the middle but maybe like 10 or
15 minutes in
like it started getting better because i
think they did like kind of
you know the the establishing [ __ ] was
like took a lit
slightly too long yeah um but other than
that like once it kind of got started up
like i got
invested in i got into like the
atmosphere of it and it being creepy and
like you weren't really sure what was
going on and it's not the movie it's not
the direction it's not the acting or
anything the score
it was the edit the edit could have been
tightened a little bit
you know which that happens a lot with
movies yeah you know what i mean
star wars was saved in edit but this
isn't like a kind of deal where the edit
ruins it it's just that
the edit i think would have made it a
little bit better if you tightened it up
that first half hour yeah
just saying yeah i mean so like i said
you know
keep that in mind that this maybe is
something you need to be a little more
patient with because this is
way more like a loki like atmospheric
kind of demon movie that's not gonna
like have stuff screaming in your face
or jump scares or anything like that
it's much more
more like a con not kind of uh more like
a
was it a change thing more like a change
than george c scott yeah kind of it's
more of that kind of vibe where it's
like so much stuff and then like the
stuff that happens is like low-key but
it's still like
yeah and it starts building up but it's
still creepy she's messing with [ __ ]
satanism and stuff
yeah so yeah and uh there's also like
another character that's like a guy who
wrote
like a an occult book like an occult
primer or something like that and heard
all her
and all her little friends are all like
big fans of this guy like they even go
to like his book signing and stuff so
she's
so he's like the one that she calls like
to to get some help like when she's like
oh hey i summoned the demon to kill my
mom and then oopsie me and my mom made
up and now i don't want her to die
anymore
so it was kind of like you know um and i
will say the end of this
it's uh this had a good ending i thought
um it's it's i'm not gonna spoil it
you liked it yeah yeah i liked it i
likes the kind of ambiguous
in a way you know what happened but
you're not really sure why
i'm pretty sure it was demon yeah yeah
well and i you can't really spoil it
because that's the whole thing of the
movie
yeah but i really did like the way they
ended it because i was like whoa all
right
the demon did what it was harsh
demon did what it was what it was
supposed to do and what it was rumored
to do it got you but not in the way that
you
are don't [ __ ] with that satanism that's
the lesson
yeah yeah you hear that you goth kids
yeah
it's the same thing as middle eastern
lore
about the gin a general grant you wish
but it's gonna [ __ ] cost you
it's it's that same concept well yeah
and it's just kind of like um
you know this goes back to like people
that were like wiccans and stuff like
that they always say like if you do bad
[ __ ] that shit's gonna come back and
bite you in the ass like three times
worse
yeah so this is basically the same
principle um
which is why you should only like if you
do witchcraft you should only do good
[ __ ]
right do bad [ __ ] yeah like worse shit's
gonna happen to you
and uh yeah that's that's generally
the case kind of you know
in islamic law jin is a demon or yeah
it's the same thing it's just the virgin
creature it's living in another
dimension uh
some some jinn or christians and some
gender muslims and some jinns are
satanic
and some of them are just farmers and
have sheep and [ __ ] but they have all
these powers
and you know they thought that a a wise
what they call them a majir of vizier or
something
they could um uh enslave a gin
and it would have to serve you and do
make you make wishes for you and [ __ ]
you know fulfill wishes yeah
but they were crafty and uh
they'd twist that wish around to [ __ ]
you up because they were pissed about
being enslaved
well understandable yeah that's where
that that's where all that genie and the
bottle and
gin stuff all came from yeah that's what
because they're like
not it's not even tricksters there's
like you said they're just mad at having
to be enslaved having to like do what
your ass wants all the time yeah so it's
like they're gonna
take everything as literally as possible
or they're gonna give you [ __ ] that you
want but not in the way that you
expected
right exactly and that's kind of uh the
theme of this as well incidentally
if you would like to see a good movie
about a gin
more like a ghostly kind of thing than
you should watch under the shadow
which is on netflix or it was like when
i watched it
that's like a um it was maybe an iranian
guy
like who i guess he was born in the uk
but he's from like an iranian family
and uh so yeah that was also a really
good
movie as well so uh anything else
would you that you would like to add
about that
i think so yeah we're gonna i i had
totally forgotten
like because i just like i said i just
signed up for hulu the other day just
on a whim or whatever and i had totally
forgotten that they had
castle rock on there and i was like well
[ __ ] i'm gonna they're already two
seasons in i'm gonna have to start
watching that [ __ ]
hulu's free isn't it no no it's uh five
i think it's five dollars a month or
five ninety nine yeah you have to watch
commercials though i think
yeah well for for movies you just watch
one commercial at the beginning and then
there's no more
okay if you watch like a tv show then
it's commercials like regular tv
you know what i mean because we started
watching my strange addiction last night
because you got that on there
it's five four five and six four five
three seasons
people eating weird [ __ ] black girls
eating sand
and that girl that ate sand also chewed
on nail files
yeah weirdest [ __ ] ever they didn't send
her to a dentist weirdly they just sent
her to like a regular doctor
i just like okay so i have to say though
i know that people have weird
proclivities and i know that some people
have a thing where they eat weird [ __ ]
okay but i will say right here
and i'm taking a stand on this some of
the people on my strange addiction
i think are bullshitting yeah the dude
that was in love with all the inflatable
animals i think was [ __ ]
i think that dude is trolling yeah i
think it was trouble because that
i mean that guy and the guy that was
having sex with his car
yeah like i don't remember what season
that was yeah i think that guy was also
true
because i think it's kind of like a
thing where you remember like back in
the heyday of like the shitty
daytime talk shows like geraldo and
sally jesse raphael and everything it
has that tone
it has that tone to it so i think i mean
a lot of the people that were on those
shows
were just actors or just like paid
people that were supposed to come on
there and like
you know they're supposed to make an
entertaining show essentially um
so i think the same thing might apply
because i mean here's the they had those
they had that couple that was taking
coffee animals i was just gonna say
it was some weird [ __ ] man we're not
talking about like a cup of coffee
they were like putting a whole pot of
coffee in their ass laying on the side
and they had kids and [ __ ] they were
working from home and they'd like put a
whole
pot of coffee up in their ass up in
their butt and then just sit there on
their side
several times a day four times a day and
they wouldn't they wouldn't stop they
would go to the doctor dr phil said
don't do that and there's one
don't do that we're gonna get a second
opinion that's what they said
and i was talking to jenny i was
thinking well you know it can't be the
same as drinking it
because it's not going through your
digestive system it's not going through
your liver it's going right
into your [ __ ] bloodstream right into
your bloodstream so i was thinking it
must have a cocaine-like effect
they were addicted to it they were
talking about how awesome it made them
feel
yeah so i'm thinking that's probably
hitting them like cocaine i wonder
[ __ ] don't try it well yeah don't try
this at home
well like that you might get addicted
that's really sad that you actually have
to say
please don't like stick coffee up your
butt well
it's here's the thing when he caught his
wife doing it he thought that [ __ ] was
gross and she talked him into trying it
and
he's doing it awesome yeah he got
addicted to that [ __ ] so i was thinking
it had like a cocaine-like effect bend
over time i'm going to put some decaf
up here now the decaf ain't going to hit
your heart
i'm going to put some of that starbucks
christmas roast up here
remember i remember you know
when i was in my we'd hear these [ __ ]
rumors these college kids [ __ ]
taking enemas from [ __ ] vodka enemas
pour a whole [ __ ]
yeah half a bottle of vodka up in their
ass and lay there for a second then it
explodes on out of them but then they're
[ __ ] up i mean [ __ ] up i've heard of
that and i've heard about like people
soaking vodka and tampons and like
sticking up i've heard of that too
i i don't i don't know how uh widespread
that is
damn i mean i imagine there's only
because this is what i was saying to him
last night the thing about the coffee
animal is the thing but i don't know if
those people really do that [ __ ] or
whatever
but it's like okay you have to think
that out of all the i know there's
millions people in the u.s or whatever
but out of all those people the amount
of people that like
have a mental disorder where they eat
weird [ __ ] that's a very small
percentage
and that out of that percentage it must
be a much much smaller percentage of
people that would actually
want to go on national tv and be like
hey
i shoot coffee up my butt and you know
and then they have to like film you
doing it like
laying there on the [ __ ] floor with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] with the hoes and
everything
and so i just kind of suspect that
i just suspect that a lot of those
people are bullshitting now i'm not
going to say that about all of them
because there was this one poor lady on
there they
they they had it where um
they kind of framed it as she was
addicted to baby wipes
but the her issue was not so much that
it was that
she had been sexually abused many many
times like as a child like for a very
long time
and um well in the shower or like
or like whoever sexually abused her put
her in the shower before this
abuse and then after the abuse so the
sound of the shower
gave her panic attacks so she didn't
want to take showers because the sound
of it like freaked her out so much so
she just started like washing with baby
wipes
you know what i mean so she had other
issues so that's like not
it's not the same that's not the same
like i felt i just felt bad for her
and um she did really seem to you know
make some progress because they got
they're doing like exposure therapy like
you know i had a big old fat girl who
was eating hair balls off a cat buffer
cat that was a [ __ ] weird one and i
was sitting there saying
okay i will say right here i don't like
lick
pooky okay i don't lick my cat however
i have been known to kind of go like on
the top of her head
you know what i mean not licking her
yeah but it's like i do get like some of
her hairs in my lips sometimes like i do
like smoocher on the top of the head and
stuff
that's like saying that that girl was
eating whole balls of hair off yeah she
was kind of like
eating balls brushing swallowing
brushing it off and then making it
making like a
like a ball out of it and then eating it
and she had and her cat was super cute
too it was like a black and white one
and i just loved that every time they
had like a shot of that cat it looked
like horrified
yeah like it was like looking at the
camera going like what the hell
i was like you can't make that [ __ ] up
yeah all right so uh
that'll do it for today's matinee
um i guess what's today okay so today's
wednesday wednesday yeah
so we don't stream tomorrow or friday
however we will be back on saturday
with uh what i think is going to be
actually a really interesting
show uh so yeah we'll see you guys next
time live
on saturday and we'll talk to you bye